unless you've been hiding under a rock
lately you've probably noticed a little
game called player unknowns
battlegrounds and all the other games
chasing that sweet battle royale formula
actually if you're playing battlegrounds
hiding under rocks probably something
you're doing anyway there are a number
of games in 2018 that should consider
the Battle Royale treatment while
business is good so let's talk games
number one battlefield 1 see what I did
there
battlefield has always been a fantastic
sandbox with large maps such as band our
desert from battlefield 3 and the
ability to introduce new modes such as
scavenger mode from battlefield 3
scavenger mode took place in a city
ravaged by earthquakes where players
picked up random guns with random
amounts of ammo inside and tried their
luck battlefield already has a huge
assortment of vehicles and could offer
either relatively smaller faster
versions of battle royale or really nail
that military theme plus battlefield
still has some of the most satisfying
gun handling mechanics and directional
sound design in the business it's a
no-brainer really
second up I'm looking at you Ghost Recon
wildlands this game always felt like an
unrealized sandbox with Tom Clancy's
name slapped on the front its mechanics
emphasize [ __ ] around far more than
tactical gameplay and somehow its
multiplayer mode ended up taking place
on small maps without vehicles I can't
think of a game better position to
become battle royale ready particularly
as it ages it has a massive map with
tons of different biomes and weather
conditions it could offer combined arms
a large variety of weapons and possibly
enemy AI it's also already playable for
solo in squads I can't speak for the
back end of this game and if you can
really handle those larger player counts
but Battle Royale could be wildlands
final form third up is the division
speaking of open-world games with
incredible environments the division not
only could do battle royale it sort of
already did with its survival DLC what
this game could offer the formula is
cover based shooting weather impact
enemy AI that could force players to
work together temporarily incredible
urban settings and the thing we always
wanted the dark zone to be but it never
really was I'm not gonna claim that the
shooting mechanics of the division are
up to the level of battlegrounds but it
does have rewards that feed back into
the main game which can be more
satisfying than pulling clothes out of
loot crate's people are looking for new
end games right now
and with the 1.8 Update
players are given the division another
shot fourth state of decay because
zombies man were coming back around to
the idea of dayz and how zombie survival
games led to pub G in the first place
but it is awesome to have to think about
your gunshots attracting the undead it
makes players think more before shooting
and also gives purpose to some pretty
useless melee weapons from pub G not you
frying pan plus tracking other players
by following a trail of zombie bodies
does sound pretty cool it also solved
some of the slow mid game pacing issues
that turn some people off of pub G we
wouldn't want the full-on aggressive
undead from Daisy
but shambling hordes and car door
executions sound kind of amazing v would
be far cry 5 Far Cry combines some of
the better shooting mechanics of an
open-world game with some of the fun
gadgets you'd find in for tonight
including a wingsuit and parachute Plus
that a grappling hook in for good
measure
Far Cry 5 also has some pretty dangerous
wildlife which would be hilarious
imagine watching a player rocking just
the machete being chased across an open
field by a stampede of angry cows unfair
sure babji's unfair by Nature
far cry is also known for trippy healing
products imagine not knowing if that
mushroom will restore your health or
make you start hallucinating and get
attacked by satanic moose maybe we're
going a little too silly here but hear
me out maybe not
alright so what are your ideas for other
games that should go battle royale in
2018 are you playing for night do you
like it more or less than pub G did you
play dizzy back when and miss that janky
zombie stuff let's talk about it in the
comments below and we'll see you in your
battle royale game of choice
you
[Music]